the Prime Minister and I have made a
promise to the British people to stop
the boats we are committed to delivering
on that promise we've got an
unsustainable problem that we need to
fix and whilst of course we are
disappointed with the decision today we
will be putting in an application to
seek permission to appeal the Judgment
very very swiftly system is rigged
against the British people it's as
simple as that that's why we're changing
the laws through our illegal migration
bill that's why we are rolling out a
groundbreaking partnership with Rwanda
which we believe is lawful with a with a
country that we believe is safe so we
need to change the system we need to
change our laws that's how we're going
to stop the boats